we're investors in quicknote and i see
that's on the list can you explain how a
company like that gets on the list yeah
no i mean they provide a valuable
service in terms of helping their
partners actually use and understand
blockchain technology
and
i think the fact that they're able to
sort of do the the dirty hard work in
terms of you know setting helping people
set up helping them build apps helping
them uh deal with things like
you know figure out how to use the node
uh stuff along those lines um they
yeah they're they're doing a valuable
service um they've also just seen a huge
boost in revenue um they have a pretty
solid revenue model um and they're
already working with big clients so to
me those factors made them perfect for
the list awesome and so hannah when you
see something like that like how
important is revenue for uh you know the
quick note is one example but there's a
ton on here uh when i was looking
through the list i saw some that
literally have no revenue some that have
very very impressive revenue and so like
how did you think about the importance
of revenue uh given that some of these
companies are very very early stage and
still somewhat speculative yeah i mean
audience for example doesn't have any
revenue but in that case i thought this
was uh
you know this was an entity really
approaching web3 in a really smart way
and it's also you know taking on the
music industry and to me that was really
really fascinating um so i think you
know i tried
sort of adapting my view depending on
you know which company i was talking to
whether you know they were earning
revenue or not um and sort of thinking
you know kind of future outlook and to
me audience seems like they could be a
big player in web3
even though there's not really a revenue
model they're working on it um but at
the end of the day most of the money
spent on that platform is going to go to
the artists
got it john you don't know this
two of the top six companies on the
crypto top 50 list we're investors in
that's that's pretty good good list
great list uh kate we talked last year
and uh we did a whole big deep dive on
uh fintech and kind of everything that
was happening there it feels like and
you mentioned uh a little bit earlier as
well that uh some of the fintech
investors now are kind of fancying
themselves crypto investors uh it just
feels like maybe the lines are blurring
and so how do you think about it from
like a coverage standpoint are crypto
companies fintechs or fintech crypto
companies does it matter
like just what do you think there yeah i
think it's a good question i think
a year ago i would have said you know
they're 100
different categories there's not much of
an intersection there and slowly that's
that's changing i think what you'll see
is the existing fintechs and you've seen
you know companies like robin hood and
others already do this but start to
really embrace crypto um whatever that
means for their business model
lately in the conversations i've had
with fintech ceos i've asked like how
does crypto fit into your roadmap and
there's definitely a mixture of people
who are kind of in denial about
needing to incorporate that into their
roadmap and others who are really
excited about it kind of just depending
on how excited you know they are as
people about the web 3
movement and everything that's happening
but
i mean i think you know down the line
those will be under one umbrella but
they're still separate because a lot of
these companies that are
really big fintech companies just have
nothing
in their business having to do with you
know currencies or blockchain technology
at all so until that changes they will
probably be continue to be treated
as different categories but like i said
before i do think you're gonna see a lot
of investors in fintech totally shift
away from that toward crypto next year
and
look look only for fintechs that are
also somehow web 3 companies or
considered web 3 companies
yeah and one of the things i guess as
part of that conversation is uh we've
seen microstrategy tesla square all put
bitcoin on their balance sheet uh are we
watching or seeing any of these startups
do the same thing like the crypto native
ones i think it's just inherently with
their business model they have it but in
the fintech specifically uh we've had uh
one of the co-founders of ramp come on
and they didn't buy bitcoin for the
balance sheet they put some of the
balance sheet and stable coins to try to
earn a little bit more yield what are
you seeing there with these kind of like
more traditional fintech firms and what
they're doing with their balance sheets
yeah that's a good example i think
i've asked ram kind of similarly about
incorporating crypto into their
company's future i i think it's early so
the
the
the general mainstream interest in web3
as you know is very recent i think um
you know that's something that happened
in pretty much like the last quarter of
this year so i think next year one of
the big stories that i
i'm sure write about in several
different ways is going to be the
massive pivot whether branding or more
serious but pivot toward web3 um in all
categories i mean you're going to see
creator economy consumer
fintech
enterprise truly all these companies are
gonna try to do that so i think it is
early i like i cur like currently i
probably wouldn't have a lot of examples
of companies i know are doing it
definitely talk to some early stage
companies that have said like we are
repositioning toward web3 or we're
rebranding like in that way but i think
we're gonna see sort of a hilarious
amount of that in the first few months
and going into the rest of next year and
it'll it'll be something that people
will probably make fun of but will
certainly be happening